[Musik]
meine wichtigste Botschaft zu Beginn die
Regierung hält an ihren Zielen fest wir
treiben den klimaneutralen Umbau unseres
Landes kraftvoll voran wir stärken den
sozialen Zusammenhalt und wir stehen eng
an der Seite der Ukraine in ihrem
Verteidigungskampf gegen
Russland diese drei Ziele uns
unverändert klar ist aber wir müssen mit
deutlich weniger Geld auskommen um diese
Ziele zu
erreichen guten Abend willkommen zum ZDF
Spezial die nachfolgenden Sendungen
verschieben sich um etwa 10
Minuten es ist keine Kleinigkeit
innerhalb weniger Wochen 17 Milliarden
zu finden um den Haushalt fürs nächste
Jahr zu finanzieren nach Ampel typischem
wechselseitigen blockieren ist das jetzt
gelungen ein Kompromiss bei dem alle
drei Regierungsparteien Zugeständnisse
machen mussten und die Schuldenbremse
weitergilt die Opposition spricht von
trixserei politisch zeigt der Vorgang V
allem1 die Regierung ist entschlossen
weiterzumachchen britter
Bucholz dem Gesicht nach zu urteilen
führlt sich Christian Lindner als ein
Gewinner der Verhandlung bis 5 Uhr
morgens hatte er mit dem
Wirtschaftsminister und dem
Bundeskanzler gerungen die Liberalen
verhinder mehr neue Schulden anders als
es SPD und Grüne wollten kommt keine
Haushaltsnotlage für die Ukraine
jedenfalls erst einmal sollte sich die
Situation durch russlandskrieg gegen die
Ukraine verschärfen etwa weil die Lage
an der Front sich verschlechtert weil
andere Unterstützer ihre ukrainehilfe
zurückfahren oder weil die Bedrohung für
Deutschland Europa weiter zunimmt werden
wir darauf reagieren müssen die FDP
stemmte sich strickt gegen Steuer
Erhöhung nun wird vieles dennoch teurer
Plastik Kerosin und Benzin sollen anders
besteuert werden der Wirtschaftsminister
zeigt sich zufrieden mit dem Abbau
klimaschädlicher Subvention doch er muss
kräftig sparen wir werden die
Umweltprämie also die Förderung für
immobile auslaufen lassen früher beenden
sie läuft ja eh aus aber werden das
früher tun und wir werden bei einigen
Programm Teilen kürzen beispielsweise
bei der Solarindustrie das tut mir weh
nach den Statements geht es
Regierungserklärung in den Bundestag
viele der Minister müssen nun Geld
zusammenkratzen besonders die
bauministerin und der
Landwirtschaftsminister
östimir kritisiert bereits die
agrardieselstreichung für Landwirte die
Opposition sieht in alldem eine
Mogelpackung das was sie hier als ein
geordnetes Verfahren dargestellt haben
ist in Wahrheit und so hat es ja auch
ihr Parteivorsitzender richtig gesagt
eine
handfeste regskrise gewesen die sie
heute morgen allenfalls mit einem
Formelkompromiss abgeschlossen
haben es ist wie so oft in der Ampel
alle drei lassen Federn aber keiner zu
viele damit endet die Haushaltskrise
jedenfalls erst einmal denn viele Fragen
bleiben noch
offen in Berlin begrüße ich den
Bundesfinanzminister guten Abend her
Lindner einen schönen guten Abend ich
grüße Sie auf der Suche nach den
fehlenden Milliarden schlagen sie
massive Einsparungen vor vor allem auch
bei Klimaschutz und
transformationsprojekten also da wo es
um Investitionen geht und um eine
konkurrenzfähige Wirtschaft gefährdet
das nicht den Standort Deutschland nein
wir investieren weiter auf einem
Rekordniveau deutlich mehr als vor der
coronapandemie und wir mobilisieren
nicht nur öffentliche Gelder für diese
Zukunftsbereiche sondern wir senken ganz
konkret auch die Steuerbelastung im
nächsten Jahr werden für die Menschen 15
Milliarden weniger Lohn und
einkommensteuerfällig und wir reduzieren
für das produzierende Gewerbe die
Stromsteuer um 3 Milliarden das sind
alles Beiträge für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
und um die Menschen zu entlasten die
Bundesregierung will an ihren Zielen
festhalten erklärtermaßen also
Klimaschutz und Soziales z.B aber es
gibt natürlich auch da Kürzungen etwa
beim Bürgergeld wie verträgt sich denn
das das ist erforderlich wir müssen
unseren Sozialstaat treffsicher machen
und deshalb unternehmen wir jetzt
Anstrengungen um die geflüchteten aus
der Ukraine in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren bei den Verweigerern von
Arbeitsangeboten im Bürgergeld muss es
Sanktionen geben und deshalb ist es
möglich 1,5 Milliarden Euro im Bereich
des Bürgergeldes einzusparen ich glaube
da hat die Bevölkerung ein dringendes
Interesse daran dass diejenigen die
Leistung empfangen das nur sol lange und
soweit tun wie das erforderlich ist denn
das Ziel ist die Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt die Schuldenbremse bleibt
im nächsten Jahr nicht zuletzt sie haben
darauf bestanden aber es gibt ein
Hintertürchen wenn es die Lage in der
Ukraine erfordert dann ist eine neue
Notlage möglich und damit das Umgehen
der Schuldenbremse also doch wieder eine
trichserei nein ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit es ist für den
Staat immer möglich bei einer
außergewöhnlichen Notlage die sich
seinem Einflussbereich entzieht und die
auch die finanziellen Möglichkeiten des
en Haushaltes überschreitet einen
solchen notlagebeschluss zu fassen aber
das kann man gegenwärtig nicht
voraussehen das ist keine Spekulation
die jetzt angezeigt ist und da gibt es
auch keinen Automatismus die Lage wird
dann bewertet wenn sie da wäre
gegenwärtig benötigen wir das nicht klar
scheint ja zu sein dass durch die
Erhöhung des CO2 Preises Benzin und
Heizung teurer werden zahlt also der
Bürger die Zeche nein der CO2 Preis
steigt auf das Niveau dass die
Vorgängerregierung die große Koalition
vorgesehen hatte tatsächlich wollten wir
weniger belasten als die große Koalition
wir kehren auf den alten preisfahrt
zurück aber ich mache darauf aufmerksam
dass wir ja um 15 Milliarden Euro bei
der Lohn und bei der Einkommenssteuer
nächstes Jahr entlasten der neue CO2
Preis der Macht 1,3 Milliarden aus also
die Entlastung sie ist wesentlich größer
als der höhere CO2 Preis sie wollen ja 3
Milliarden sparen bei den sogenann
klimaschädlichen Subventionen was heißt
denn das genau wir haben Subventionen
wie beispielsweise eine besondere
Steuerfreiheit bei den Kraftstoffen für
die Binnenschiffahrt und seit vielen
Jahren wird das als klimaschädliche
Subvention bezeichnet und diese alten
Subventionen die im übrigen auch unsere
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
nicht berühren die laufen jetzt aus aber
damit finanzieren wir eine
Steuerentlastung nämlich die Senkung der
Stromsteuer für das produzierende
Gewerbe im gleichen Umfang also aus 3
Milliarden alten Subventionen machen wir
eine Steuerentlastung für die Betriebe
die angesichts der gestiegenen
Energiepreise im weltweiten Wettbewerb
stehen das ist ein Beitrag zur
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit Herr Lindner
vielen Dank für das Gespräch ich danke
Ihnen
Herr das Gespräch haben wir
aufgezeichnet so ein Bundeshaushalt ist
eine komplizierte Sache der jetzt
gefundene omiss auch manche Details
müssen noch abgestimmt werden und doch
sind die Konturen des Milliarden
schweren Sparpakets erkennbar was
bedeuten die Maßnahmen konkret für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger susanne polmann
hat sich das genauer
angesehen am Ende werden es wohl auch
viele kleine Haushalte merken wenn im
großen Bundeshaushalt das Geld fehlt der
eine mehr der andere weniger also
konkret wo werden die Verbraucher die
Einsparungen warnehmen nehmen z.B beim
Tanken und heizen mit fossiler Energie
Sprit Heizöl und Gas werden wohl teurer
denn der CO2 Preis soll zum 1 Januar
2024 stärker steigen als ursprünglich
geplant fliegen dürfte teurer werden
denn auf innerdeutsche Flüge soll eine
Kerosinsteuer eingeführt werden
abgeschafft werden sollen so manche
klimaschädliche Steuervergünstigungen
heißt Landwirte müssen wohl in Zukunft
auf den günstigeren Agrardiesel
bedeutet höhere Kosten für sie aber auch
klimafreundliches bleibt nicht von
Kürzungen verschont so soll die
Kaufprämie für E-Autos früher auslaufen
und die Förderung für Solaranlagen
gekürzt werden keine Reduzierung
sozialer Standards beteuert der
Finanzminister dennoch sollen 1,5
Milliarden bei Sozialleistungen
eingespart werden z.B beim Bürgergeld
die Kindergrundsicherung soll
unangetastet bleiben sonst wenig
greifbares unter anderem möchte man
geflüchtete Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
schneller in den Arbeitsmarkt bringen um
so weniger finanzielle Unterstützung
leisten zu müssen es bleibt alles noch
ein wenig Waage denn jetzt sind erst
einmal die Ministerien dran die die
Vereinbarungen umsetzen müssen erst
danach wird es für die Verbraucher dann
wirklich
konkret in Berlin begrüße ich den
Wirtschaftsexperten Marcel fratcher
guten
Abend guten Abend herroff die
Schuldenbremse bleibt die Milliarden
sind gefunden alles gut
oder nein das was die Bundesregierung
jetzt entschieden hat ist keine Lösung
für die langfristigen Probleme man hat
die Prioritäten sehr klar gesetzt keine
weiteren Schulden Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse keine steuerliche
Belastung stärkere Belastung gerade für
hochvermögende
aber Investitionen werden dadurch
gekürzt und das schädigt die
Zukunftsfähigkeit Deutschlands ja
kurzfristig holt es die Kuh vom Eis aber
durch diese Unsicherheit wie es denn
nach 2024 weitergibt ist das letztlich
auch keine gute Nachricht für die
deutsche Wirtschaft geht es denn bei dem
gefundenen Kompromiss gerecht
zu der Kompromiss hat eine starke
soziale Schieflage es sind vor allem
Menschen mit wenig Einkommen die hier am
stärksten belastet werden und am
wenigsten entlastet werden erstens durch
die Kürzungen bei den sozialausg haben
beim Bürgergeld aber auch durch die
Erhöhung der CO2 Bepreisung das sind ja
die KonsumentInnen Konsumenten die dafür
zahlen und jetzt besteuert der Staat
noch stärker CO2 BürgerInnen zahlen das
aber gleichzeitig gibt die
Bundesregierung dieses diese Einnahmen
nicht in der Form eines klimagelds an
die Menschen zurück so wie es auch im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochen wurde und
die 15 Milliarden Euro an Entlastung bei
den Einkommensteuer die der
Bundesfinanzminister erwähnt das kommt
ja fast ausschließlich den
Spitzenverdienern zugute Menschen mit
wenig Einkommen haben davon so gut wie
nichts wird denn das was da mit heißer
Nadel genäht wurde bestand
haben ich befürchte dass dieser
Kompromiss der jetzt gefunden wird nur
kurz anhalten wird denn die Frage wie
Ausgaben 2025 und danach finanziert
werden sollen die ist ja ungelöst die
Politik muss sich ehrlich machen sie
muss darüber reden wie sie wirklich
Ausgaben dauerhaft kürzt wie sie
beispielsweise steuerprivil ien
reduziert wie sie Subventionen für
fossile Energieträger
abbaut das bleibt die Bundesregierung
nach wie vor schuldig Deutschland steht
vor einer extrem schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen Transformation und hier
bleibt die Bundesregierung die Antwort
schuldig wie will sie die notwendigen
Investitionen in eine gute Infrastruktur
in den Bildungssystem auch in
Innovationsfähigkeit und Klimaschutz
finanzieren und das ist mit diesem
Kompromiss nicht gelöst Herr frcher
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
sehr
gerne kurz vor Toresschluss also haben
sich die drei ampelpartner geeinigt das
gibt allen eine gewisse
Planungssicherheit und vor allem die
Gewissheit dass neuewahlen die mancher
in der Opposition öffentlich gefordert
hatte erstmal vom Tisch sind wie weit
die Beschlüsse im nächsten Jahr tragen
das muss ich allerdings erst noch zeigen
das war unser ZDF Spezial vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse wir geht's gleich
weiter mit Hotel Mondial auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen